it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we celebrate the fourth of
July with Saints Row 4 national treasure
edition for now only coming out is the
national treasure Edition will be
available in both digital and physical
forms and includes the base game plus 29
DLC packs the DLC has two missions
including enter the dominatrix and how
the Saints save Christmas as well as
some weapons vehicles and hopefully
something Nicholas Cage
Saints Row for national treasure Edition
will be available July 8th for $29.99
next come hang out with your good old
pal straw hat Luffy with one pieces
latest game unlimited world red
challenge the diabolical Don Quixote as
he seeks to destroy you and any
windmills in his way the game comes with
DLC at launch titled the red stands
alone but why it's an add-on and not
just in the game in the first place is a
true mystery it'll drop on the
PlayStation 3 Wii U and 3ds July 8th
also this week you can get your evil
scientist on with mouse craft coming to
all things Playstations think lemmings
but cuter as you manipulate the maze the
mice must run through to obtain their
precious cheese you'll probably never
see such a silly race for cheese in all
your life oh wait
well the testing begins July 8th also a
tactical 8 player co-op survival game
jumps from early access to officially
released with red solstice let me set
this up in the not too distant future
when earth is toast in Mars is home
there's a beastly storm called the red
solstice and they lost contact with an
important colony called the capital so
they sent a team of eight nobodies to
find out what happened to them chances
are they're all dead it's like the
expendables the video game shoot him up
July 10th
finally Adult Swim games offers us this
cloudy gem with super combo man giving
us classic 2d fighting in a sticker
themed style and a fanny pack attack try
and master the combat to fight it out
through all 16 action-packed levels if
you're into that for further details
visit GameSpot's new releases page
release states are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week